- [Narrator] In movies like Carrie,
blood comes by the buckets.
Perfecting that red gooey
mess took a long time
and several different recipes.
This is the story of how
fake movie blood is made.
Back before film and TV, a
simple red handkerchief on stage
symbolized blood, but
it was kind of boring,
so some theaters upped the ante
by boiling a bug known
for its red pigment.
They used the cochineal bug
because it creates red dye.
When black and white movies came along,
pigment didn't matter,
so Hollywood simplified things
by using chocolate syrup.
Then in the 1930s when
black and white movies
turned to color, Hollywood
needed a new blood trick.
Enter John Tinegate, a retired
pharmacist living in England.
He concocted the most
realistic looking blood yet
called Kensington gore
using a combination of
mostly golden syrup, food
coloring, corn flour and water.
The most famous of the
blood recipes though
comes form a man named Dick Smith.
He came up with something on par
with the Julia Child recipe.
The catch, his recipe was poisonous.
One ingredient, Kodak Photo-Flo
is deadly when consumed.
So people started replacing
the poison with creamer
and other items that won't kill you.
Today a lot of the fake
blood you see on screen
is computer generated, but
if you want to be legit,
it should be poison or bugs.
(intense music)